l'agriculture verticale c'est moins
d'eau moins d'espace aucun pesticide une
méthode qui maximise la culture
horticole et ça ça veut dire plus de
pouces et de verdure fraîche à l'année
dans votre assiette
ça pousse en hauteur parfois très haut
et même très très haut
l'agriculture verticale c'est à dire en
hauteur et étager se développe très
rapidement depuis 2010 c'est l'avenir
c'est l'avenir c'est ici maintenant
à la ferme en plein cœur de Montréal une
ferme intérieure
à la ferme d'enrosemont en plein
donc c'est tellement l'occasion on parle
de il faut que ça soit local local puis
c'est vrai ça sort carrément de cette
magnifique chambre ici là cette pièce là
c'est juste 50 tours dans le bâtisse on
est capable de entrer environ 350 à 400
tours ça c'est le début du projet
qu'est-ce que vous cultivez ici
on a beaucoup de choses on verra
ensemble genre de lecture on a des choux
frisés
la petite entreprise familiale de Tchad
et France établi dans ce local
industriel fournit les habitants ainsi
que quelques restaurants et épiceries du
quartier Rougemont
de deux kilomètres de le faire et puis
c'est hyper localisation c'est notre
goûts
[Musique]
vous venez à peu près à quelle fréquence
chaque vendredi
nous ajuster le moment de la récolte
pour que la requête soit plus ou moins
longue ou plus ou moins amer
à ma
brasse
sont des reviennent de la ferme voisine
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire avec ce
que vous apportez aujourd'hui
la qualité de l'ingrédient
de l'élever l'eau il doit être en fait
là on va faire une salade de légumes
vraiment bien simple
les fermes verticales utilisent des
technologies parfois surprenantes ici
les racines poussent dans ses tours en
aéroponie c'est-à-dire dans l'air sans
substrat
ce sont on entend l'eau c'est ce qui
coule là
l'avantage de ce genre de culture c'est
de maximiser l'espace disponible dans un
environnement totalement contrôlé
[Musique]
on est capable de contrôler les lumières
la fréquence l'intensité tandis que une
serre traditionnelle par exemple il
dépendent sur le soleil
la ferme urbaine hydroponique aquavertie
produit depuis 6 ans en verticalité
toutes ces verdures se vendent en
supermarché
on a un espace de production d'environ
20 000 pieds carrés puis ceci est
équivalent à une terre agricole
d'environ 30 hectares et si on a une
hauteur de 19 pieds de haut puis on a 7
étages superposés
95 personnes moins
15% moins d'eau mais c'est de l'eau que
vous recycler comment ça fonctionne
parce que là ça coule
dans le bassin on est capable de
réutiliser pendant trois mois ce que tu
m'as donné la dernière fois c'était
parfait moi j'utilise les
gros farcir puis les petites pour autre
chose
t'inquiète êtes-vous restauratrice oui
que vous venez acheter vos produits ici
absolument on est juste à côté nous
c'est quoi votre restaurant Le Rose fait
qu'on est dans l'hyper locale Tchad nous
a abordé puis moi j'ai dit bah si c'est
bon je suis d'accord et c'est excellent
en Ontario et en Nouvelle-Écosse Good
Life la première ferme verticale au pays
cultive déjà des verdures à grande
échelle en hauteur
et bientôt à Calgary ainsi qu'à
Longueuil dans cette immense bâtiment
c'est à peu près 100 000 pieds carrés
comme on est vertical on peut mettre
plus de récoltes si tu veux par
superficie fait qu'on est à peu près 25
fois plus dense qu'une ferme
conventionnelle avec ça on va pouvoir
remplacer les produits qu'on importe
l'hiver de la Californie du Sud
des technologies inspirées du Japon et
d'ailleurs dans le monde pour des
produits frais toute l'année on est des
fermiers en premier on a nos sources
vraiment agricoles nous sommes très
fiers et puis on amène la technologie ou
c'est opportun
860 000 kilos de verdure seront produits
chaque année ici à Longueuil ça va
ressembler au prix du biologique c'est
ça
c'est puissant comme goût là est-ce
qu'on peut faire pousser autre chose que
des verdures quand même on a même juste
pour le fun pour se dégradés ici on a
poussé des petites carottes comme ça
c'est pas profitable aujourd'hui parce
qu'on a besoin à cause de la
consommation énergétique on a besoin de
produits qui poussent rapidement et non
pas qui concerne des mois pour les
récolter c'est pas la solution magique
qui va sauver et nourrir tous les 10
milliards de personnes qui vont être
majoritairement dans des villes urbaines
d'ici 25 ans mais ça a été une solution
clé qui va aider énormément à libérer
plein de terrain agricoles qui sont
utilisés pour la production de l'étude
par exemple